nasa versus the ussr is one of the
biggest rivalries
of all time the ussr put the first
satellite into space
while nasa put the first animal into
space soon enough
the ussr put the first human into space
while nasa put the first human
on the moon despite this fierce
competition in the early days
as the cold war came to a close both
countries actually started to work
together
they collaborated on the iss and nasa
even fully relied on ross cosmos to send
us astronauts
to the iss for nearly a decade more
recently though
the countries have started to go their
own ways once again
with nasa embracing american launches
and russia looking to ditch the iss
and move to their own space station so
if the countries were to enter a new
space race
who would be the space champion today
well to answer this question we're going
to take a look at five different
categories
starting with launch capability when it
comes to launch capability
nasa is not off to the greatest start as
they were fully relying on was cosmos
for several years
now nasa is relying on private companies
including spacex and
potentially boeing however when it comes
to in-house launch capability
nasa doesn't shine in any way they don't
currently have an in-house rocket
capable of human spaceflight
and they've been working on their
upcoming sls rocket for several years
sls is expected to boast an impressive
payload capacity of 70 metric tons
and nasa is looking to build an even
larger sls with 130 metric tons
of payload capacity but aside from large
payload capacity
sls doesn't really bring anything new to
the table
in fact the saturn v which was used to
take astronauts to the moon in the 1960s
and 1970s
had a pillar capacity of up to 140
metric tons
so sls isn't even that impressive when
it comes to payload
as for ross cosmos while their rockets
aren't nearly as large as american
rockets
they're more than enough for the
purposes they serve moreover
whilst cosmos has six different
operational rockets right now
which is infinitely more than nasa's
zero rockets
the first two rockets are the angara 1.2
and the angara a5
these two rockets are designed to launch
satellites and commercial payloads with
capacities of 3 500 kilograms
and 24 000 kilograms respectively the
next two rockets are the soyuz 2.1 a
and the soyuz 2.1 b unlike the angara
rockets
these rockets are capable of human
spaceflight and boasts payloads of 7000
to 9000 kilograms
whilst cosmos also has the soyuz 2.1 v
which is a rather small rocket designed
for payloads of up to 2800 kilograms
but that's not it ross cosmos also has a
proton m
which is capable of 23 metric tons of
payload
aside from all of these rockets ross
cosmos also has four rockets under
development
including armor soyuz 5 yensei and
dawn all of these rockets are expected
to be completed within the next 15 years
and have payload capacities ranging
between 10.5
and 140 metric tons so there's really no
competition
in this category ross cosmos is clearly
the winner
moving on to reliability it's kind of
hard to judge nasa's reliability today
as they haven't launched anything
themselves in 10 years
so we're forced to use a space shuttle
and the saturn rockets when judging
nasa's reliability
fortunately for nasa the saturn family
of rockets were star performers
they completed a total of 32 launches
with a success rate of
100 now that's really quite an
achievement
the same thing however cannot be said
about the space shuttle the space
shuttle completed a total of 134 flights
out of which two were complete failures
that killed 14 astronauts
in terms of percentages the space
shuttle had a failure rate of 1.49
which is rather high especially for a
rocket that promised reusability
as for ross cosmos on the other hand
they've mastered reliability
russia has simply been upgrading and
iterating their soyuz rocket for 50
years at this point
so they've been able to perfect
basically every aspect of their rocket
the last time russia had a fatality
during a mission was with soyuz 11
in 1971 which killed three astronauts
even then though the fatalities weren't
because of the rocket
soyuz 11 was visiting salyut 1 which is
the first space station in the world
unfortunately the undocking procedure
damaged the breathing ventilation valve
which eventually suffocated the
cosmonauts before this
russia also had another fatality in
april of 1967
with soyuz 1. this time the problem was
because of the rocket
as the pair should fail to deploy
properly during descent
but aside from those two incidents ross
cosmos has had no other fatalities
now you might be thinking that both ross
cosmos and nasa had two major accidents
in their history
so the reliability should be similar but
here's the thing
between the saturn rockets and the space
shuttle nasa has completed a total of
166 launches
meanwhile ross cosmos has completed 1680
successful launches with
soyuz alone so there's once again no
doubt in this category
as well as cosmos wins reliability by
far
having a plethora of awesome rockets
alone however is not that useful
the goal of building and launching
rockets is to complete various missions
and
projects so let's take a look at the
projects both countries are working on
this is where nasa begins to shine as
their missions are much more meaningful
when compared to ross cosmos
who has basically just become a
transportation service between the earth
and the space station
after nasa reached the moon in the 1960s
the soviet union went into full gear
trying to send astronauts to the moon
and even mars but after the soviet union
dissolved
russia basically just gave up on the
moon and mars
if russia really wanted to i'm sure they
could have placed consonants on the moon
within the last 30 years
but they just never really focused on
doing so russia does have a plan to send
humans to the moon by 2030
but nasa has plans to do it in 2024
it's unlikely that either of these
missions will end up happening on time
however given that there is a six year
gap between the two missions
i feel pretty confident in saying that
nasa will return to the moon
before russia gets to the moon for the
first time aside from sustaining their
lead with the moon
nasa is also looking to place humans on
mars in the 2030s
ross cosmos has also said that they plan
to place humans on mars in the late
2030s
but if they can't beat nasa to the moon
i'm not sure how they're going to beat
them
to mars moreover these missions don't
even seem to be russia's primary focus
right now it looks like most of their
focus is going towards building their
own space station
considering this nasa seems to have a
much brighter future when it comes to
main space flight
so nasa wins this category next up we
have cost efficiency
generally ross cosmos would crush this
sector as their rockets are
significantly cheaper than nasa's
rockets
we don't exactly know how much it costs
ross cosmos to launch soyuz
but we can't form a good estimate whilst
cosmos originally charged nasa 50
million dollars per seat on soyuz in the
early 2010s
as they realized the monopoly they had
though they started to pump up the price
pretty quickly last may boss cosmos
charged nasa
90 million dollars per seat but this was
likely just because they could
not because it actually cost them that
much the 50 million
ticket price was likely much closer to
how much it actually cost russia to
launch astronauts on soyuz
soyuz is capable of carrying three
astronauts which works out to 150
million dollars per flight
factoring in a bit of profit soyuz
likely cost russia 110 to 120 million
dollars to launch
it may even be a bit under 100 million
like 80 or 90 million
but we'll call it 120 million to be
conservative that works out to 40
million dollars per seat
as for nasa the last in-house crude
rocket they launched was the space
shuttle
and that averaged a massive 450 million
dollars per mission
the space shuttle could carry 8
passengers though so that works out to
56.25 million
or 40 more expensive than soyuz
considering this
the point would generally go to ross
cosmos but there's one major factor to
also take into account
which is nasa's commercial crew program
i didn't want to include spacex rockets
when comparing nasa's launch capability
with russia's
because it isn't nasa's technology but
when we're looking at cost efficiency
i think it's fair to include spacex
rockets because it is nasa's money
moreover nasa has been one of spacex's
largest funders from very early on
and nasa is the primary reason that
spacex was able to even develop cool
dragon
when it comes to technology it's more of
an intellectual property battle
and in that case nasa can't be credited
with spacex's intellectual property
in terms of cost efficiency though it's
more of a return on investment battle
and nasa can be credited with clever
investing
nasa estimates that each seat on the
falcon 9 costs 55 million dollars
but that's because nasa invested so
heavily into the research and
development of falcon 9.
as nasa continues as an astronaut on
falcon 9 though that price will
dramatically reduce
as spacex only charges 62 million
dollars per commercial falcon 9 launch
which works out to less than 10 million
per seat if nasa uses all seven seats
so nasa's more investing with the
commercial crew program wins in the
category of cost efficiency
and that brings us into the last
category which is innovation
and longevity starting with innovation
this should have been a category
on its own but the problem is that
neither nasa nor ross cosmos
is particularly innovative right now
russia is straight up using a rocket
that they developed in the 1960s
nasa isn't quite using a rocket from the
1960s
but they're basically rebuilding saturn
v with sls
so nasa isn't doing much better than
ross cosmos aside from their rockets
either country has really pushed forward
human space flight or exploration
in decades so i don't think either
country
is really worthy of the innovation point
and that leaves us with longevity
though neither nasa nor ross cosmos are
innovative on their own
nasa once again has a bit of leverage
due to the commercial crew program
about a decade ago nasa realized that
politics and congress were heavily
limiting their progress
so they launched a commercial crew
program and this has proven to be
extremely successful
launches aren't the only industry that
nasa is commercializing though
they've also hired commercial help on
their lunar mission and they're looking
to render out the iss to commercial
tourists and researchers
nasa's embracement of the private space
industry has reinvigorated american
space flight
and it's likely that the entrepreneurial
spirit will push nasa much further than
politics can
ever push ross cosmos so this point
also goes to nasa meaning that nasa is
the space champion
today do you guys agree comment that
down below
also drop a like if you would love to
see nasa be innovative
once again and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one